in our series a more perfect union we
like to show you that what unites us
as americans is far greater than what
divides us
so earlier this year we showed you a
program helping seniors to stay
connected
during the pandemic
pirate radio run by retirees
i love this story that's 88 year old bob
coleman boys and girls broadcasting
the radio show they call it radio
recliner something for us to look
forward to in our retirement years i
have a feeling i'm going to get there
before you like that here
i remember that story i loved it still
love it
chip reid spoke to a few of these
stay-at-home djs about how this creative
program provides an outlet
while they're stuck inside
good afternoon friends this is bob
featherstone
for residents at senior living
communities across the country
now my dj name bumski a new
internet radio station is helping people
tune in
and stay connected hello radio recliner
listeners
we are kind of you know socially tied
down right now because of a thing called
the virus
lee flynn has been on lockdown for
months at his facility outside atlanta
there's a lot of people here
but i walk down the hallway and it's
like
a haunted house it must be tough for you
because you come across to me as a very
sociable
extrovert i don't know whether that's a
compliment or not
jimmy but it is it is difficult it is
difficult for everybody
now flynn and other seniors can create
their own playlists and record
hour-long shows for an online audience
without even
leaving their rooms is it all right
hattie miles is known at her community
in alabama
for her collection of hats she wanted to
share
a message of love with her show which
debuted
on juneteenth i feel wonderful about it
i can remember when i was younger we
used to do a lot of fun things
with juneteenth day why did you pick a
change is gonna come it's something that
was
written years ago and it still sounds
good today
it's true it's something that we would
like to see happen
we like to see things come for the
better you've got your own show
how does that make you feel empowered
you feel empowered
yes i feel that i have something to
offer
hey there this is dolly parton that
message has attracted some
big name attention you're doing a great
job for giving residents like charles
smothers a way to connect
to family and friends as soon as i heard
his voice i burst into tears
the music he picked i felt like i was
just back in the car
growing up listening to him sing and the
songs that he loves
it's sort of become a social media for
seniors
mitch bennett launched the program at
bridge senior living facilities in 14
states but has now had requests
from around the nation there's something
about old-time
dedication radio that really resonates
with
with these residents and music has so
much meaning and kind of creates these
vivid memories
ed rosenblatt known as dj windjammer
plays the ukulele on his show and the
piano for his community
every evening we can't have more than 10
people in a place at one time but if
someone's passing through the area
they'll stop and they enjoy the music
and it makes me feel
good and that's how you feel about radio
recliner too it's an outlet
absolutely it's an outlet for the the
djs who are doing it and it's again it's
something else it's an hour for people
who are listening
is radio stardom in your future you know
anything is possible
i'm i'm waiting for my phone to ring and
i'm available
for cbs this morning chip reid
washington
what's your dj thank you chip read i
love that piece
yeah tariq and anthony now i know what i
want to do when i grow up i want to be a
radio recliner
good question anthony i've got my next
career
good question what's the dj name anthony
i love jericho's question
i don't know yet i'll come up with one
and get back to you it's got to be good
it's got to be as good as boopsie
it's got it jerika what's your what's
your dj
how about dj ricky
do it